là vous êtes un peu le blondinet à
l'école et les mômes se moque de vous
quoi et pas seulement que j'étais blond
c'est que j'étais extrêmement beau
bonsoir bonsoir avant de passer à l'art
divio le magnéto de Blacko Laurent
1978 il y a de satouf né à Paris d'un
père syrien et d'une mère bretonne ils
partent vivre en Libye puis s'installe
en Syrie ou Riad vivra jusqu'à l'âge de
12 ans sa mère le ramène alors en France
il passe son bac à Rennes où il fait les
Beaux-Arts avant d'étudier l'animation à
l'école des Gobelins à Paris 2000 Riad
publie sa première BD intitulée petit
verglas le scénario n'est pas de lui et
son dessin est encore assez classique
c'est en 2002 qu'il affirme son style
graphique avec le manuel du puceau à
partir de 2005 il publie chaque semaine
dans Charlie Hebdo la vie secrète des
jeunes puis on le retrouve dans Fluide
Glacial où il crée le personnage de
Pascal Brutal super-héros aussi viril
que débile
2009 Riad se lance dans le cinéma son
film Les Beaux Gosses révèle l'acteur
Vincent Lacoste et décroche le César du
meilleur premier film en 2010 les beaux
gosses de riads
c'est une chronique sur l'adolescence
basée sur les personnages d'Hervé à dos
de 14 ans plutôt un rat physiquement
moyennement malin et débordé par ses
pulsions la même année il obtient aussi
le Fauve d'or à Angoulême pour le tome 3
des aventures de Pascal Brutal Riyad
tourne alors un second film Jacky au
royaume des filles une comédie qui se
déroule dans un pays où les hommes sont
soumis à la dictature des femmes le film
sort en 2014 mais c'est un échec
commercial Riyad quitte à leur Charlie
Hebdo abandonne son personnage de Pascal
Brutal et rejoint le Nouvel Obs où il
raconte chaque semaine la vie d'Esther
une vraie petite parisienne de 10 ans
2015 Riad décroche un nouveau pauvre
d'or au Festival de l'Angoulême cette
fois pour le premier tome de l'arabe du
futur une BD autobiographique sur son
enfance en Syrie les trois premiers
tomes seront traduits en 22 langues et
ce vendront à un million et demi
d'exemplaires à travers le monde le
quatrième tome sort en 2018 et détrône
carrément Zemmour du sommet des ventes
Riad a même le droit à son exposition au
Centre Pompidou
2019 l'infatigable Riad sort le
quatrième tome des cahiers d'esthers qui
a maintenant 13 ans forcément on
enchaînant les succès de cette façon pas
étonnant qu'il soit ce soir chez
Ardisson
tout de suite on passe à la grande
interview de la semaine l'art divio
bonsoir d'abord c'est un plaisir de vous
recevoir c'est la première fois que je
vous reçois dans l'une de mes émissions
c'est comme premier rendez-vous vous
buvez quoi là c'est de l'eau fraîche de
l'eau fraîche vous êtes dit quoi dans le
taxi merde je vais devoir dire à quel
âge je me suis fait violer par un animal
en Syrie
non pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
je me suis je me suis dit que j'étais
très content de venir parce que je vous
ai regardé très très souvent à la télé
et c'est un petit ça fait un petit effet
un petit choc d'être avec vous ça me
fait très plaisir c'est comme moi le
jour où je ferai Drucker j'ai déjà fait
tout le monde l'a fait sauf moi alors
Riad vous êtes l'auteur de nombreuses BD
à succès la vie secrète des jeunes
publiée d'abord dans Charlie Hebdo
Pascal Brutal les cahiers d'ester et
bien sûr l'arabe du futur votre enfant
semble BD qui vous a valu de nombreux
prix et qui s'est vendu pratiquement à 2
millions d'exemplaires il est également
cinéaste avec les beaux gosses et Jacky
au royaume des filles BD ou ciné tout
part toujours du dessin en tout cas fait
quand même parce que vous savez que
dessinateur aujourd'hui c'est un métier
à risque un petit peu comme patron de
bistrot à Marseille ou CRS le samedi
[Musique]
viens faire des bulles viens faire des
des
5 mai 1978 d'une mère bretonne et d'un
père syrien c'est lui qui a gagné pour
le prénom en même temps Gwenaëlle ça
touche ça aurait été bizarre donc c'est
mieux que ça soit Riad quand même alors
on vous apprenez rien mais quand on voit
cette photo vous avez vraiment une tête
de petit breton quand vous étiez gosse
dire petit breton d'ailleurs vos enfants
sont blonds oui bah oui tout à fait
comme quoi alors cette photo a été prise
en Libye vous avez habité pendant votre
jeunesse votre père Abdel Razak était
enseignant ici d'une famille très pauvre
il était un brillant élève il avait
obtenu une bourse pour étudier en France
il a fini quand même par décrocher un
doctorat d'histoire à la Sorbonne tout à
fait alors reste eu de la Sorbonne notre
père a rencontré votre mère Clémentine
oui en fait mon père parlait très très
mal français c'est un énorme
[Applaudissements]
un rendez-vous il demande un rendez-vous
à la copine de ma mère et ma mère lui
dit non non mais laisse tomber en fait
il est collé à fond et lui dit d'accord
demain 19h Place de l'Opéra et elle se
casse toutes les deux et en fait elle
pensait le planter mais ma mère a eu
pitié de lui et elle est allée au
rendez-vous et voilà je suis lâche
que vous soyez là alors en 1982 alors
qu'on propose à notre père dans saigner
à Oxford il choisit la Libye ensuite
vous poserez vos valises en Syrie près
de Home et vous dites mon père était un
nationaliste arabe il était pour sortir
le monde arabe de la servitude et vous
les participez à l'éducation du monde
arabe en fait c'est un admirateur de
Nasser il était dans le panarabisme il
était bassiste d'une certaine façon
après il a été islamiste au départ il
était laïque bassiste comme tout c'est
dictateur du Moyen-Orient il était
fasciné par Saddam Hussein
si c'était sa grande s'agrandidol en
fait parce que déjà c'est dedam Hussein
était sunnite comme lui il adorait aussi
à faisait Lassad mais c'était pas comme
il était à la weed c'était pas mais
Saddam Hussein en fait il pensait avoir
un destin comme comme Saddam Hussein
village misérable et c'était enfui
ensuite il avait il avait rejoint son
oncle qui lui et qui lui avait appris à
élire et à écrire en fait des années
plus tard il avait fini par faire un
coup d'état donc mon père pensait qu'il
aurait un destin exactement semblable il
rêvait de faire des coups d'État il mais
quand Saddam Hussein a été arrêtée il
était très humilié votre père c'est vrai
qu'en fait il est voilà il était c'était
quelqu'un d'assez brutal aussi comme
Saddam Hussein qui avait fait progresser
l'Irak de manière incroyable il avait
construit des routes il avait eu un prix
de l'UNESCO pour l'alphabétisation de
son pays mais il exécutait ses opposants
à tour de bras de mon père pensait comme
ça votre père était d'extrême droite on
peut le dire oui moi je pense qu'il
voyait on peut vraiment dire qu'il est
d'extrême droite il admirait pas
seulement Saddam Hussein il adorait
Pinochet
j'avais le peigne il pensait que c'était
le plus grand homme politique français
c'était l'homologue de Saddam Hussein en
tous les cas votre père il voulait que
vous alliez à l'école il vous disiez tu
vas à l'école parce que l'arabe du futur
lui il va à l'école ce qui a donné le le
titre de vos célèbre exactement bande
dessinée alors vous étudiez le Coran
mais vous faites semblant de prier vous
y croyez pas du tout il voulait à la
fois que je grandisse dans les mêmes
conditions qu'il y avait été les siennes
c'est-à-dire dans une école de village
avec des enfants très religieux etc et
en même temps il exigeait réellement en
disant je suis un moderne tu fais ce que
tu veux etc je te force pas il y avait
ces deux ces deux choses qui se
mélangaient
à l'école et les mômes se moquent de
vous quoi sont hyper racistes avec vous
en fait ce qui se passait quand vous
avez pu le voir sur la photo c'est pas
seulement que j'étais blond c'est que
j'étais extrêmement beau et donc
comme on déteste les beaux en général
souvent non seulement j'étais beau mais
en plus j'étais extrêmement lécher qu'à
l'école j'étais il y avait des ultra
bonnes notes j'ai des tout le temps avec
les profs j'étais
insupportunités passaient mettaient
leurs mains dans mes cheveux blonds
enfin c'était donc en effet il m'aimait
pas trop j'avais pas beaucoup d'amis
ouais c'est vrai alors comme vous avez
pas d'amis vous évadés vous commencez à
dessiner ce qui est pas très bien vu en
Syrie et vous lisez Tintin que votre
grand-mère bretonne vous envoie c'est ça
c'est ça c'est exactement ça c'est comme
ça tout a commencé parce qu'en fait il y
avait pas de livre dans le village où on
habitait pas de livre en arabe du tout
même ma mère mon père ne lisait pas les
seuls livres qu'il y avait c'était les
Tintin de ma grand-mère bretonne et donc
j'ai appris à lire le français en lisant
Tintin voilà à l'âge de 11 ans vous
rentrez en France donc avec votre mère
et le retour est aussi violent que la
vie en Syrie parce que ça n'a rien à
voir évidemment avec la société que vous
connaissez
est-ce que c'est plus compliqué d'être
breton en Syrie ou arabe en Bretagne
en France en fait j'ai jamais souffert
vraiment de racisme ou de ou de
stratisation si ce n'est le fait que mon
nom était ridicule mais bon il y en a
d'autres qui ont des noms débiles mais
voilà c'est vrai quand on fait la peine
en classe ça tourne
c'est vraiment c'était pas c'était pas
il y avait il y avait une moindre
considération je dirais en France on
faisait moins attention à moi alors
exemple de choc culturel vous savez pas
comment aborder une fille parce qu'en
Syrie c'était un petit peu interdit et
quand une fille tombe amoureuse de vous
elle nous fait des avances vous
n'arrivez pas à l'embrasser et elle
raconte à tout le monde que vous êtes
impuissant j'étais partagé entre deux
pôles c'est-à-dire j'avais mon père qui
est devenu de plus en plus
traditionnaliste et n'arrêtait pas de me
répéter que les femmes étaient le diable
et qu'il fallait pas leur parler et
qu'il fallait pas les regarder qu'il
fallait se marier plus tard etc et mon
grand-père Bretagne qui lui était ultra
obsédé sexuel avait extrêmement peur
donc que vous soyez homo il était très
homophobe et donc dès qu'on marchait
dans la rue ils disaient oh regarde
celle-là tu as vu je c'était un moment
les hormones avaient peut-être pas
commencé à fonctionner je pense que je
regardais j'ai aucun effet
voilà alors quand on est comme ça coincé
entre deux pôles
c'était difficile de choisir ce que si
on par rapport à l'autre forcément
j'allais décevoir donc je crois que
c'est assez à ce moment là que j'ai
choisi une identité
qui n'existait pas dans ma famille en
fait ni du côté syrien ni du côté breton
c'est l'identité des gens qui font des
livres et qui racontent des histoires et
j'ai choisi ce peuple là est-ce que
votre grand-père vous a emmené faire du
naturisme
Thierry vous voulez trop savoir la suite
de la et je sens que vous êtes un
extrêmement bon lecteur pour la suite
[Musique]
alors hier vous êtes ici ce soir pour le
quatrième tome des cahiers d'Esther
intitulés histoire de mes 13 ans le
pitch esther est en 5e elle quitte
l'enfance elle entre dans l'adolescence
alors extraordinaire c'est que la vraie
Esther vous avez commencé ses aventures
quand elle avait 10 ans et c'est la
fille d'un couple d'amis parisiens donc
un jour elle se confie à vous et vous
dites c'était comme si un extraterrestre
me parlait de sa planète c'était comme
si j'avais ouvert une radio sur un
une petite porte mais si mais ça ferait
des BD génial de lui laisser la laisser
parler sur son sur sa vie sur son
quotidien et donc je me suis dit je l'ai
proposé je lui ai proposé elle en avait
absolument rien à [ __ ] elle m'a dit
oui pas de problème ses parents étaient
d'accord j'ai changé les noms les lieux
etc pour prendre la retrouve pas je me
suis dit que ce serait marrant de faire
un album
une semaine vous raconte des trucs vous
les retranscrivez évidemment d'abord
dans l'Obs et ensuite dans des livres et
sur Canal et vous lui reversez les
droits d'auteur en fait elle est elle
dort là elle est pas au courant qu'elle
a quelque chose vous mettiez sur un
compte pour quand elle aura 18 ans
c'est vrai que des fois on lui a offert
des albums d'Esther sans savoir que
c'était sa propre vie c'est arrivé elle
à la fois des copines qui lui offrent la
BD à Noël elle a aussi des gens qui lui
demandent son avis sur cette BD si c'est
réaliste etc donc elle est elle commence
à y penser pas mal alors dans ce volume
la jeunesse terre s'intéresse à
l'adolescence aux garçons évidemment
balance ton porc les fake news parce
qu'elle a une copine complotiste la
pauvreté la drogue la mort de Johnny et
même Macron il y a qu'à un moment elle
rêve qu'elle coach Macron avant une
rencontre avec Poutine oui oui c'est
vrai est-ce qu'elle pense que Poutine
est un facho elle a ultra peur de
Poutine
facho pour elle parce qu'il veut limiter
l'usage du portable
j'imagine non non elle a très peur de
Poutine alors qu'elle n'aime pas avec
Vladimir Poutine c'est que elle sent
bien elle est bretonne déjà et ça avait
profond vraiment marqué sa famille quand
je passais à parler à grand monde mais
il y a des avions russes qui sont passés
près de la Bretagne il y a quelques
temps et ils avaient été interceptés par
des rafales donc elle c'était comme si
il venait menacer la Bretagne donc elle
a elle a gagné
sa tête alors autre actualité un an
après avoir fait votre entrée dans le
petit Robert vous avez dessiné la
couverture de la nouvelle édition il y a
des nouveaux noms propres dans le petit
Robert il y a Jay-Z Kanye West Mbappe
Griezmann vous avez des plans pour y
entrer non
vous avez dit
la langue française et mon pays préféré
oui c'est vrai non non c'est vrai je
suis obligé de l'admettre en fait le la
langue française n'était pas la première
langue que j'ai parlée j'ai parlé
l'arabe et justement à cause des livres
comment envoyer ma grand-mère en
Bretagne le français était la langue de
l'évasion c'est la langue avec laquelle
je pense aux histoires avec laquelle
j'ai envie de raconter des trucs et tout
donc c'est vraiment un j'ai beaucoup
d'affection pour pour le français je
sais pas comment
merci Thierry
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu